háblenos del impacto global que se
espera que tenga este acuerdo sí este
acuerdo como usted bien lo mencionado es
un acuerdo que podríamos decir histórico
no no solamente comprende la formación
la posibilidad de formación de áreas
marinas protegidas que en el caso de
latinoamérica potenciaría lo que
pudieran ser corredores de protección en
el en Centroamérica del lado del
Pacífico como también de Perú y chile en
la protección del conjunto de la
Cordillera de nazca sino también incluye
aspectos relacionados con la
contaminación estudios de impacto
ambientales restricciones minería de
baltamar en aguas profundas que es una
preocupación
importante como también que es un
elemento siempre de tensión en los esta
negociaciones globales la equidad entre
el norte y el sur Respecto a los
beneficios de genéricos que se
encuentran en ese sentido creemos que
es bastante más completo
y complementa las aún insuficientes
organismos regionales de ordenamiento
pesquero como el que existe en
específico tour que se enfoca sobre
determinadas especies específicamente y
que no tiene resultados que todos
señor suegro de acuerdo con la ong de
protección Marina de Mission Blue
América Latina es la región que va a la
cabeza de la creación de áreas marinas
protegidas que cambiará para la región
con este acuerdo creemos que eso va a
posibilitar como mencionaba el por
ejemplo la formación de un área Marina
protegida en altamar que incluya el
conjunto de la Cordillera de nazca esta
cordillera este está presente a lo largo
de varios miles de kilómetros y varios
de ellos están fuera de la
jurisdicciones tanto de Perú y de chile
y que posibilitaría entonces la la
conformación de un corredor de esa
naturaleza con importantes
contribuciones respecto a la protección
de especies que son ahora explotadas de
manera intensa como es el calamar
gigante principalmente flotas
extranjeras fuera de nuestra de países
ribereños como también del jurel es una
de las especies que la urop del pa
regula Igualmente
refuerza los procesos que ya se han
estado realizando para poder incluir
desde Galápagos hasta
Costa Rica un corredor también de
protección Marina que creemos que se
potenciarán con este acuerdo bueno Que
sigue ahora de quienes depende que este
pacto se ponga en marcha y que además
funcione en primer lugar que los países
los suscriban No es cierto hay un número
determinado de países que necesitan los
los oscuridad Para que entren en
vigencia ya lo que queda son procesos
administrativos propiamente para que el
acuerdo esté listo y sea firmado no por
los países en el caso en particular del
Perú también tiene que ser ratificado en
el congreso cada país tendrá su proceso
Y de esa manera poder contar prontamente
con un acuerdo con un instrumento
vinculante como es el que ha acordado
esta instancia esta conferencia
intergubernamental